so a lot of the fast movies have
directors cuts and extended cuts when
you're putting something like that
together
what is your priority is it including
things that you really wish that people
got to see in the theatrical cut is it
about enhancing the story what's what's
the order of priorities there
it's different i mean
you know i think on fast five
it was about sound design
it was it was really weird i think in
the evolution of like the how you
release a film
fast five the extended cut really we had
to remix that to the way i i really
wanted because there was mpaa you know
and so that that was the experience on
that one
um on on a lot of times it's really for
pacing i think especially for this the
ambition of this film
you know the collision of like so many
different narratives and i do feel like
with time f9 will be the film that's
going to connect not only the other
films
but other stories in the universe you
know and so um that being said i think
the seven and a half minutes it's not
because i i didn't like it and i took it
out of the theatrical it was just the
theatrical cut was already two and a
half hours are really more for pacing
but there's a lot more um explanation
and also kind of shared uh uh
reasons for our characters when you
watch it and i think that
again down the line when people want to
watch
like when it's all said and done and
they want to watch to connect everything
the extended cut will be the one where
it will answer more questions i could
feel it while i was watching it so
you know i have to look ahead because
we're greedy we love this franchise and
i can't help it i heard you're shooting
the next two movies back to back and it
was making me wonder what is something
that's on your mind that could pose a
significant challenge for you being the
leader on two gigantic films shooting
back to back but then on the other side
what is something about shooting two
films that way especially the end of the
saga that you think could benefit the
material
look the the there's an ambition of what
we want to do and there's also uh
real world issues
you know that that we're we're
encountering
but you know i i feel like
for for me it's i don't want to be
greedy you know i want to do what's best
for you know the process
and so
um
the idea of of the the last chapter
being two films is correct i i have to
say i i i'm so glad that you know
because i think
when i first entered this franchise a
sequel was not given
it you had to earn it you know and so to
be sitting here talking to you and go oh
yeah we're gonna be there's gonna be two
more movies like wow like it means a lot
you know and so
um
so every day when i wake up i'm trying
to like
reconfigure and make sure that hopefully
whatever we're talking about process
wise
is gonna yield the best result you know
and um but i think you know having one
chapter and two movie is correct that
that's where i sit today i believe in
that respect so
over the course of this movie's run i've
spoken to so many people and everybody
highlights your attention to detail
so can you think of a specific thing
whether it was a whole scene or a very
tiny detail that people might not notice
that you harped on in this movie that
you want to make sure they see this time
around
that is
you that is the toughest question i
i have i had finished and wrapped this
movie i've uh
and
if you were to just warn me i would
probably give you like
eight different examples i get the sense
there's like a laundry list of things
yeah and and i mean look i think that's
part of the fun i have doing these films
is that you know i think with every
actor talking through their character
like narrative
and the the tragedy is that ninety
percent of what we talk about is not
even on screen
you know
um but i think
hopefully
soon while we'll find the right medium
and the right uh
avenue to be able to bring those stories
to life
but
um
i enjoy it i enjoy it i enjoy every
little thing
and i think that that is the to me
that's one of the secret ingredients is
that you know sometimes doing these big
movies
to be able to show up on set
and um
oh man like there's so many
there's so many but i'm drawing a very
simple like maybe even like a like a
production design detail
like a costume design element
well it's funny i i we were in london
and um
they're like oh so uh
han snack
and i said oh man we gotta get on it
because it just can't be a regular snack
and uh talking to sung
i think they had to go
like they had to import those crackers
you know um and i was adamant i was like
we cannot fake
han snacks it doesn't matter and so
because
having worked with song like even the
way he tosses it you know it had to be
natural so like i remember that was a
big thing that was like uh one of those
things where they i think that even
props were at first were like oh yeah
just snacking i'm like no
no
so that that was a great one i like that
he just built a han food basket for me
and now i kind of want that to be a
reality so i can buy it